we're continuing our conversations with
a number of different candidates running
in these 2022 midterm elections and
today I'm going to be speaking with
Bobby pyton Bobby is a republican
running for election to the United
States Senate to represent Illinois and
Bobby's worked as a portfolio manager
he's on the Republican primary ballot in
Illinois on June 28th the winner of that
primary will face incumbent Democratic
senator Tammy Duckworth in November uh
Bobby great to have you on I appreciate
it thank you so much for having me you
know these conversations as many in my
audience always tell me can be so
Illuminating because I as someone of the
left want to hear the ideas of people
that are Republicans and and that are on
the right and sometimes the ideas make
some sense and sometimes they don't and
we talk about it and we we sort of
figure it out and talk through things so
just to start I've been doing this
almost like as a just gut check to to
start figuring out where people are so
forgive me if the answer to this
question is easy who's the current
president of the United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a it's a funny it's a
funny question is it really yeah I do
think it we live in a very interesting
time
where
um we have there's forces beyond our
visibility that uh like Supernatural
Supernatural not Supernatural oh there's
there's a group of extremely uh well
wealthy Beyond wealthy like suit uber
wealthy individuals not just in the
United States but globally okay that
call the shots on both parties not just
one party okay and and so it's it's
almost as though there's a bunch of
horse trading taking place behind the
scenes and so you know from that
perspective I do believe the will of the
American people
um was ignored in 2020 and uh the person
that's in there is is the person that
these globalists put in and and that's
that's in and I you know what I would
tell you is
I have overwhelming proof I'll I'll
actually be releasing uh proof from
about Illinois tomorrow General Flynn
will be in town I have a fundraiser for
my campaign and vandersteel Doug
Billings Jovan Pulitzer Liz Harris from
Arizona Edward Solomon who's done work
mathematical work on proving that our
elections across the aisle folks the
unit party is very real and frankly it's
undermining you and me okay but so Bobby
that's that's a lot so let's take it
piece by piece sure who are the rich
globalists you that you're talking about
well there's
there's a there's a there's a there's a
corporate class okay uh a global
corporate class that exists that uh
considers themselves to have more rights
than any individuals within any nation
state who are they
CEOs of major Global corporations but
can you name some specific people so
like for example
um you know uh think of BlackRock
uh BlackRock controls nine trillion
dollars of assets through their their uh
their structure uh he's he's been in
control for over 30 years okay um who
has won uh Bill Gates is one who
parlayed his fortune in Microsoft into
um other areas okay
um you know so you can you can argue
that Elon Musk is one who's who's kind
of like leaning from left back to right
and possibly right for the first time in
his life okay that's another one
um you know Michael Eisner of Disney
used to be one before he retired uh
they're they're there's always this
Legacy wealth that we all know exists
like the Rockefellers
um you know the duponts for example The
Dupont family backed the individual
running for U.S Senate in Pennsylvania
there's like 4 000 duponts okay you know
and and so it's it's a it's it's not
it's not like one Boogeyman it's a bunch
bunch of people okay and so
um do you trust the results from
Pennsylvania from earlier this week
where this right-wing guy uh who
believes the election was stolen in 2020
Doug mastriano he won on Tuesday do you
trust those results or do you question
them
I think that
um that the results are are are
um what's the word I would use is uh
they're they're probably manufactured to
some degree yes so I think it's it's a
cross party lines so Doug didn't really
win
well first of all here's my question is
if if we were playing a board game me
and I and two other people and
um
and you know somehow we knew that there
was some some some stuff flawed with the
way the game was set up okay and we were
playing and you know one of us ended up
winning right but we knew that it was
flawed massively would it really feel
like a win okay but I'm asking a
different question and I love this
because we're really getting down to
Brass tax here in in 20 in the November
2020 election Joe Biden was awarded the
state of Pennsylvania do you believe Joe
Biden won in 2020 in Pennsylvania
absolutely not okay and I have and let
me explain how but but I'll let you
explain it but I want to just make sure
we go sequentially two days ago Doug
mastriano won in Pennsylvania's
gubernatorial primary do you believe he
actually won
I think that I don't I have not looked
at the data to make that assessment oh
so I looked at the data
um with regards to 2020 I actually broke
out all 67 counties of the state of
Pennsylvania and I showed how they had
destroyed entire last names of Voters
from both Republican and the Democratic
side to create the outcome that they
wanted mathematically and it showed up
in the voter registration files and the
final result they literally destroyed
695 000 individuals names
that didn't vote the way their algorithm
wanted and it's a brilliant way to hide
their crime because why didn't a single
Court accept this well first of all a
couple things number one uh that that
information was provided to the Georgia
State Senate okay wait hold on you're
talking about Pennsylvania but now
you're talking about Georgia because I I
released those results I testified
before the Georgia State Senate with the
Pennsylvania results because those votes
were shifted to Georgia
they shifted votes from Pennsylvania to
Georgia just Georgia like a stock
portfolio algorithm and who did it
people in Pennsylvania are people in
Georgia
somebody Whoever has the power to
control the the voter registration files
and the voting system of those two
states did it what person would have
control over both systems in two
different states I think that there's
multiple entities that probably have
that the the means to do that like who
let's just say the DNC and the RNC maybe
they did it together for all I know the
DNC and the RNC took control of the
Pennsylvania and Georgia systems to
shift votes from one to the other but
Biden won both so what was the point in
shifting them because because once again
I think they do some horse trading
behind the scenes both parties okay and
they and they collude to create the
outcome that they agree upon okay based
on these Mega donors all right so to go
back to the question who's currently the
president do you have an answer you can
give
I think that
um I think that right now in in the
international Arena okay of the world uh
President Biden is recognized as the
President of the United States do you
believe that someone else like maybe
Trump is actually the president
I have no information to make that kind
of judgment or assessment okay you know
so no I'm not living in a delusional
World
um you know where somebody is thinking
you know there's some kind of like uh
secret shadow presidency or something
like that no no no no I don't I don't
believe in any of that oh but I do I do
agree with
everyone musk said uh which he he said
whoever controls Biden's teleprompter is
really running this country okay I do
agree with that statement there are so
many fascinating things in a q a you did
with a paper not long ago let me
actually mention exactly what paper it
is
um it was uh it was a local newspaper
Shaw local
um The Shaw local news network you did a
q a it's fascinating before we get on to
the substance Bobby
in looking at your answers you do
something that Trump does which is you
randomly capitalize words in the middle
of sentences that aren't proper nouns so
like in your answers you randomly
capitalize the word farming and the word
chemicals and I could give you a dozen
other examples can you help me
understand what's with the random
capitalization yeah my wife uh my wife
it's a big pet peeve of hers so I'm It's
a Wonderful question and sometimes and
it's very hard because when you write
something
um you you don't always necessarily have
people key in on certain words so I do
know that it's not grammatically correct
okay capitalize I've had this discussion
with my wife plenty of times and I I say
I capitalize it because I want to catch
people's attention instead of
italicizing the word or Bolding it I do
something that causes them to pause and
so I hope it was effective with you you
know she thinks it's ineffective to
communicate this way I agree with your
wife I agree with your wife it made no
it was such a distraction because I was
like does Bobby think these are proper
nouns
no I oh
finality Quirk fairness you know to your
point my wife has brought it up others
have brought it up maybe I maybe it's
time for me to stop doing that something
to think about okay good so now let me
ask you another question in this same q
a with the news local newspaper when you
were asked about January 6th
um one of the things you said is you
really want antifa and black lives
matter investigated for what happened on
January 6th do you have any evidence
that antifa and black lives matter are
the ones that committed crimes at the
Capitol on that day
well first of all
um I'm not sure if I linked it right
with that question I might have
mentioned it in the same question but
I'd have to double check I don't have
those notes in front of me okay but in
terms of those two groups anti-first
Amendment which is anti-antifa right
it's a play on words it's pretty
brilliant uh no it actually means it
means anti-fascist well it means
anti-first Amendment well no you'd have
to the people the people who it's sort
of like if you told me my name means
something different like if I'm coming
up with the name I'm coming up with it
because I know what it means to me right
the antifa says it's anti-fascist we
have to go by what they are meaning with
it don't we well I mean that's it it's
you know it's kind of funny for you to
say that because on the left right now
there's people that identify as being a
woman that are biologically a male and
you know in in they could they could
tell you that they have to have a
certain pronoun so I I understand we're
going to agree to disagree on what it
means well right the focus is so you
were asked about the riots and what you
said about that was that it was a
peaceful Gathering manipulated by the
political establishment and you want
antifa and BLM investigated for it yes I
do think I do not have evidence you know
those two were involved I I you know but
I think that I do believe that people
from both sides of the aisle the
uniparty corrupt Democrats corrupt
Republicans were both involved in
staging this incident
um and it in a way that uh if you notice
what happened after that event yeah we
never did get to see any disputes with
you know like the you know the the floor
of Congress to debate the merits of
issues that arose in uh the ballots
properly and all these different states
they they kind of brushed through that
much faster as a result of that event
well yes because they realized that it
was going to serve no productive purpose
that at the end of the day there wasn't
really any substantive evidence or fraud
nor a legal mechanism to deny Joe Biden
the presidency and they said it's the
middle of the night we all want to go
home let's do what is obviously going to
be the correct thing to do you know what
I'd love to do David yeah I'm going to
if you don't mind yeah make sure you
send me your email address please
tomorrow you'll send me the evidence
okay I will send you a deck yeah with
regards to my presentation find some of
the slides from Tomorrow fine and I'll
and I'm more than happy if you have a
DropBox okay I'm glad glad to send you
uh some data for you to recruit from the
voter registration files of the five
Battleground States the work that I did
as well as my write-ups and I'll gladly
let you read it debate it it's all I'm
glad to do it I'm glad to do it but
Bobby in terms of my question on antifa
and BLM you believe people from both
sides were involved but I believe that
before you you said that you said you
have no evidence antifa or BLM were
involved that's what you said right I do
not have evidence because they were
involved I do think that they are based
on other things that I've seen but I
don't have the Smoking Gun so to speak
I'm not an investigator I'm asking that
there there is an investigation held and
there have been so many which have found
either that Joe Biden won by even more
or like it doesn't sound like you're
necessarily satisfied with
investigations when they don't go your
way what type of investigation would you
accept
well well a couple things yeah okay so
um number one
when you when you look at
um
um let's you let's talk about the State
of Arizona okay yeah okay so Arizona
there's Maricopa was where the audit
took place right everybody knows that
and you were involved with the Cyber
ninja stuff right I was involved with no
no I was not employed during that audit
okay work on the on the on the voter
registration files okay and proved out
that there was a set of Voters inserted
into the voter registration files that
can be called upon when needed to sway
the um the results in any particular
Precinct and they had they all were
registered to the same address is that
correct no no they weren't that's not
the case that they were all registered
to the same address oh what what happens
is
in in the case so let's let's talk about
why you need very little to to rig an
election especially when you look at the
results okay if if there was there's an
average of about 1 000 people per
Precinct in this country so if the vote
came out to be
501 to 499 you're talking about what
you're talking about a two vote
differential right 501 minus 4.99 yes so
now if you wanted to uh sway that result
the other way from 501 to 409 you only
need three votes okay you need to go
from 501 to 502 so 3 divided by a
thousand is 30 basis points it's three
tenths of one percent so a thousand goes
into one million a thousand times so per
million people that voted three times a
thousand is three thousand votes so in
the case of Arizona
3.6 million approximately people voted
so 3 times 3.6 is 10.8
000. you only need to steal 10 800 votes
to affect the election if it was 501 to
499 and you put it to 502 501 502. but
this is an imaginary scenario where
you're saying every Precinct okay all
right go ahead no but here here's what I
would say the data
is when when you mapped out the data
across the 700 I think it was 742
precincts within Maricopa I think I
believe there are 742 precincts and you
calculated what was the number that
would be needed in advance to to rig the
election and you could generate it
before a single ballot was cast and the
numbers came out the way they came out
on Election Day you would call in the
question mathematically how can somebody
come up with
the algorithm for how to do this before
a single ballot was cast what evidence
do you have that sent anybody did that
though you're just looking at the
numbers I'm more than happy to send it
to you okay I'll send you Edward
Solomon's it's coming out tomorrow right
well well I was explaining Arizona
tomorrow I'm going to explain Illinois
oh okay in Illinois
I've never exposed Illinois but I'm
going to expose uh the senate race for
Durbin that's a place in 2000 and the
senate race the U.S Senate race for
Duckworth my opponent if I make it
through the primary right in 2016 and I
will show you the data I will do a video
actually I I'm not sure if we're going
to live stream it but I will gladly send
you my supporting documentation please
my video and and I will and I'll explain
um how they're modifying the voter
registration files and using optimizers
as well as random functions that exist
in Microsoft Excel to do this anybody
will be able to replicate what I'm
talking about if they have Microsoft
Excel okay Bobby I've got to ask you
because we are out of time what would
what evidence if it could be presented
would convince you that Joe Biden just
won in 2020 does it what is there such
evidence if anybody could show it to you
that would make you say you know what
Biden won
I think the evidence that would convince
me that that Biden won is is if you said
Bobby in your state of Illinois yeah uh
there's 8.9 million people registered to
vote okay and um of those 8.9 million
people
um this is how many that you know were
between you know the legal age to vote
you know 18 plus and um um they they
they exist in our society in the form of
um you know there was six million tax
returns filed or there was a 150 you
know like 500 000 Social Security checks
paid into the state or you know 200 000
uh you know covet checks that were
cashed and and if if I can see the the
receipts of the economic activity of the
of the state of who's doing these votes
and it ties out to our federal tax
receipts our federal spend you you know
because I'm not saying you know I don't
if somebody's retired and they don't
have a a tax return and they still get
government money they still have a right
to vote so I'm all for like oh this is
how many receive the check that voted
this is how many pay taxes that voted
and then if if all of a sudden there's
no record that they exist economically
speaking you know
um you know like that would that would
put this to us for me real quick I'd be
like okay it seems we have all of that
that's strange listen Bobby we don't
have it uh we don't have a
cross-reference with the actual votes
that take place in our system at the
current time is your assertion that Joe
Biden didn't even really win Illinois is
that what you're claiming
I don't know if he won Illinois
you don't know I I I I know that he went
he I could tell you right now that in
Illinois based on my my research there's
well over
1.6 million fraudulent registrations in
the state of Illinois at the present
time
okay but so you're you're saying that
even Illinois which was won by democrats
in 2016 2012 2008 2004 2000
Etc uh 1996. I mean you're saying that
those were all fraudulent or just in
2020 the Democrats we need to look at
all the elections going back at least 20
years since the machines entered the
scene oh boy so so you think maybe even
like Bill Clinton's win in Illinois in
92 was fraudulent I didn't say that we
didn't have machines back then oh okay
96 1996. the machines came in after this
Criminal by the name of George Bush uh I
believe he stole the election from Al
Gore uh in Florida with the hanging chat
and uh incident but in 2000 and 2004
where the Dem where Al Gore and Carrie
won Illinois even though bush had the
machines you think
machines came in after the 2000 election
okay so 2004. yeah so
with his brother who was the governor at
the time yeah Jeb
um that ushered in these machines and I
think ever since these machines have
come online I think it makes it easy to
possibly manipulate and steal elections
across the whole the whole ticket okay
and look the math will show it I I'm
gonna I'm very happy I I will send you
all of my stuff and and uh and I and
it's all going to be presented tomorrow
I have over I think about 300 plus
people coming tomorrow I invited the
press to be there good and uh and uh I
will I will open it up for peer review
and people that love math and statistics
they can look at it themselves and see
what I'm talking about and love it if
you wanted to talk about it after you go
through it and pick it apart allow me to
do it yeah I will take a look at it and
then we will go from there and you know
Bobby I have a feeling you're going to
take these beliefs to your grave I don't
think you'll ever be disabused of any of
these thoughts I don't I don't think the
evidence really matters
I think I think that um you know I think
I think that what will play out will
play out but this is what I do can I
just say this yeah when this plays out
the way it's gonna be meant to play out
yep my biggest hope about this whole
thing yes is that when you have a
difference or I have a difference and
who we back that goes in you know to to
run for office that your vote is not
deluded one iota and my vote is not
deluded right now I don't think either
one of us I do not have any confidence
that my vote is not being undermined in
some way or your vote might not be
undermined in some way and so I will
continue to work to get that solved
because at the end of the day we're all
Americans first we are and uh on the
left look my my The Godfather of my son
is is is a huge Democrat he um I think
he actually you know he calls Pelosi his
girl when he was living out there he's
an airline pilot and he's The Godfather
and you know last year I loved a guy
I've known him over 20 years we disagree
but we both want it to be fair you know
and I think I think at first he was
skeptical I've sent him information over
the past year he sees it he's more
open-minded to seeing if it truly is
taking place but the reality is is in my
state of Illinois they're both in on it
folks both the Republicans and the
Democrats are doing this to us and I
don't think it was just in 2020 I think
it goes back at least two decades all
right well we're gonna look at all of it
we've been speaking with Bobby pyton who
is running for U.S Senate in Illinois he
is in a primary which is at the end of
June if he wins he will face incumbent
Democratic senator Tammy Duckworth Bobby
Illuminating I can't that quite
literally you're lit up up your face is
completely lit up
no but it's been it's been an
Illuminating conversation metaphorically
and literally hey can I can I mention to
your
check me out at Bobby python Titan come
around telegram yes and and please get
us the data on Illinois and we will look
at it very strongly awesome I
thank you